yes
coucou tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien
c'est bientôt les fêtes ouais et donc
j'avais envie de mettre mon petit
costume de Papa Noël et de vous faire
des petits cadeaux voilà j'ai donc
décidé d'organiser un petit jeu concours
sur les réseaux
et de faire gagner à 10 participants
le livre dédicacé voilà
chéri
tu es comme le bon vin
parce que je vieillis bien non tu me
saoules
pas au sujet de ma tournée c'est qu'on a
de la moquette sur scène et qu'on a donc
du coup des chaussures de scène et des
surchaussures en plastique bleu qu'on
doit apporter toute la journée pour
passer à lire la moquette et voilà ça
fait qu'on est super sexy quand on quand
on répète pendant la journée on est tous
hyper stylé
[Musique]
hello on est trop content d'être
retrouvé tous les deux et on a
rendez-vous bientôt pour la demi-finale
de la France a un incroyable talent
[Musique]
et donc je me suis tiens je vais faire
le coup du petit plat fait maison et
tout prise de retard pas eu le temps de
le faire j'ai commandé mon meilleur
deliveroo que j'ai ouvert dans une
assiette
chinois mais ça passe toujours bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]